These people are standing by Lula da Silva.
They're convinced he will be Brazil's next president despite a court's ruling...
...that makes it almost impossible for him to run.
On Wednesday, an appeals court upheld his conviction...
...for corruption and money laundering.
It even increased the sentence to 12 years and one month.
Lula is now 72.
He was Brazil's first working-class president...
...and is credited with lifting millions out of poverty.
Brazilian law bans candidates who have been convicted from running for office.
There are two legal moves Lula can make to avoid prison...
...and to fight to be allowed to run in October's election.
But for many, that will now be tougher than his supporters would like to admit.
Teresa Bo, Al Jazeera, Porto Alegre.